what all of that just established ah ah
now I have an expression and I want to
maximize this you look at the question
that says show that theater is maximized
when the viewer is and then they give
you a distance for X so here is the part
where we break out this calculus that
we've just learned and we give a shot on
these nuts okay so let's give this a go
and the first thing I'm going to do is
I'm just going to rewrite this in a form
that will make chain rule a little bit
easier for me because every time I
differentiate one of these there's a
function of the inside I've gotta
differentiate I like dealing with it
like that I'm going to write it in this
form because then I can just bring the
power out the front reduce the power by
blood it makes it a lot lot less brain
work for me okay so I'm just going to
rewrite it like this okay and now I'm
ready to launch into my derivative okay
so this is part b dig it on yet I want
to see how is Theta changing as
exchanges that's what this derivative
means so have a go ok will do the inside
and we'll do the outside what is the
derivative of the inside here can
someone just state it for me x2 that now
due to the power drops down now for this
next part I then say okay I've on the
inside I'm going to the outside now the
derivative of tan inverse is we think is
the first one we did this morning 1 on 1
plus x squared with one difference I
don't have X which is isolate their I've
got that disaster ok so I'm going to go
one on one plus that square which is 16
on x squared yep now I suppose I could
have don't you meet your next notation
like this but there's no clear advantage
there the reason this is useful is so I
get that right okay and then I'm just
going to rehearse the result for the
next part the three or next part okay so
let's just quickly do that
minus
okay now this looks like a bit of a
royal mess that's okay we're going to
deal with it don't get overwhelmed by
how long it is just step through it one
step by step also you can notice for
example see that X to the negative 2
right that means it's really negative 4
on x squared good that that's really
good for me let's go to make things nice
and neat because this x square and that
x squared are going to cancel okay so
let's quickly go through that
12
okay now if you'd like to scrutinize my
steps you're welcome to have a look
however just for the sake of brevity
because we're not we're not other words
this is just the warmup for this
question right I have derivative what am
I going to do with it what's the point
of getting stories i am i'm searching
for turning points right so therefore
i'm going to say turning points may
occur because i don't actually know tell
me points may occur when this derivative
is zero
ok now I'm going to just let that equal
to 0 but you can see the important part
that matters is this guy up here ok this
is irrelevant to me so I can say here is
the derivative and even though this
denominator is gross it's immaterial to
me ok that's equal to 0 so therefore 12
minus x square is equal 0 ok now i need
to pause for a second because just like
up here and something has disappeared
and a better account for the fact that
it's disappeared what's missing in there
alone yeah there's a negative answer
that comes out a solution of this but i
don't need it because some x is a length
right always come back so i'm going to
say here at this point would have
eliminated the negative solution x is 0
as it's a leg ok so this I think was the
part b result they want us to show this
is 233 I believe ok now i'm still not
out of the woods yet i found the place
but the question said sure when theta is
maximized at the moment I know it's
gonna probably be a turning point but
how do you ensure that let alone that
it's a maximum what do I need to do now
ok I have to test somehow you've got two
ways to test what are the two ways
tables values or secondary come on you
can see clearly I should go for the
table values here I don't even want to
think about that denominator ok so
here's what you're going to get 2 root 3
root 3 is like one point seven ish so
you double that it's 3 point something
so a nice way on the left will be three
nice i might be food ok so you're going
to have to have your table feel this is
X and later on directx you've got your
one two three values you're going to
test you already know it's going to
happen
and just because of interested in save
your time I have some value to you and
you really do need these names we've
established this before okay you can't
just say yeah it should be negative
positive a positive negative because
that's like the question tells you what
kind of tawny port it should be and
therefore you are it's an hour
responsibility to show that so this is
going ah down there's my maximum so I
can say therefore there is nice okay now
plus for a second the last question I'm
going to let you think about as I've up
this border the last part this says sure
that the maximum angle like what theater
is subtended by the picture is and then
they give you a number okay I in fact
I'm gonna write it here in another color
snack refer to it in case you this is
the number they provide that's what
they're contending theater is equal to
okay question to you to ponder arrows
are like this all how do you go about
that how do you arrive at this
expression okay we've got all this set
up you're going to do with it i'll let
you have a think while i rub all this
and get some wetness ok well let's
launch into this and let's see what
happens ok so i have an expression for
theta i showed it in part 18 whatever it
is ok theta is equal to 10 inverse of
this take away a tenuous of that and I
know what X is right so I'm going to
just launch you tan inverse of and then
if X equal to that I believe i bought
this take away this okay now you look at
that you're like okay I've got 10 verses
that's a good sign okay but how do I put
these two things together like they're
kind of messy in and of themselves and
if you go one step further what can you
say okay how much can I simplify here
and you say turn inverse of that will be
203 and this guy will be root 3 on to
route 302 is nice but not when you're
dealing with 10 so these are not like
nicely exact values right we suppose we
should know that when we look at this ok
that's what I'm going to end up that's
because it gets what am I gonna do okay
now oh yeah what I suggest cuz I could
form a right angle train which has a
theater in it yeah with this okay so
there are couple of problems with that
firstly i'm gonna need two triangles
right which were coexist but secondly
once i get them like they're where do i
go with them there aren't exact IDs that
fit on those so here is the suggestion
okay i need to get out of this messy
thing how do i get rid of 10 in verses
that are messy Ted ten will get rid of
them right if I take 10 of both sides
I'll get a 10 theorem here which is
counter-intuitive because you're like
wait I've got theater already why do I
want to make it messier answer is
because this is too messy to deal with
at the moment now watch out though this
is alpha minus beta these are two angles
so 10 of this side is Theta but 10 of
this side is not just 203 over 30 to its
10 of this
minus this which sounds to me like a
compound angle is it not this is Ted of
alpha minus beta okay I know it seems
like we've got a long way to go but I
promise you're finished before half the
school leaves okay watch tear them alpha
motor speed up right is tan of alpha
which is just too enroute 3-10 of beta
which is just rude thrilled to write
unlike before we had 10 a visit and now
I've got tan of tan inverse which is
always the same that that's just y
equals x forever right divided by 1 plus
tan alpha which is two hundred three
times tan beta which is root 3 on 2 this
is just one ok so this looks a bit messy
here but once you deal with the surge
and that's all that's left you should
come out the bottom with this and you
look at that oh no it's as simple as it
gets it's not the number i wanted yes it
is all we have to do is multiply through
and that gives you this but don't forget
this is 10 feet up one last step take
invest in and then yacht